i really feel like i deeply understand
the finance and the sales piece
right now marketing i thought
marketing was supposed to be with sales
now you've broken it and put it on a
different cadence
why well sales feeds off
marketing okay but marketing feeds off
product
okay so that's why that's why marketing
is on the same cadence as
product it's amazing because it's like
just saying that
it's so logical but nobody's written
that down
it's it's so obvious product gives
marketing something to market
and then marketing gives those leads to
sales yeah so so basically in a startup
most news that a startup generates will
somehow be product
news right sure so marketing feeds off
product product
it gives marketing the grist for the
mill um if the startup
stops shipping you know the the the mark
of the news starts becoming
kind of fake and manufactured right um
oh we had to hire we hired somebody
or we raised money it's not we released
this new feature right that is going to
blow you away you need a demo of this
feature
startup news should really be product
centric right
because if you're not shipping great
product what's the point yeah i mean
it's
it's it's innovate or die right i mean
and this is why our friend
elon is just or steve jobs
they or or benioff you know they've
become incredibly good
at this cadence of releasing
product after product now some of them
are duds some of them are not important
some of them fall flat but some of them
like the cyber truck
people won't shut up about okay so that
that's a great point those are the
examples i give in my blog
and here's the trick that they figured
out is that you need to have a launch
event
to focus the world's attention so just
putting out a press release
is not good enough it doesn't penetrate
the clutter you have to combine
a live demo of your new product and then
you know you add other things you talk
about
new customer logos you talk about your
growing market share you talk about
financing news
you can include you know the new metrics
or milestones that you've hit
you can include partners in the
announcement in customer stories and
anecdotes
all of that matters and you can include
it but the heart of it
it always starts it revolves around a
live product demo
and so what we're really talking about
here is a launch event
and you know if you think about like
what benioff does with dreamforce every
year
um i mean it's you know dreamforce is a
launch event i mean they do all the
other stuff too
there's partners and customers in all of
it but they're
always presenting a ton of new products
which is a forcing function
for the product team so now the
marketing team
has said we rented this space
we put our uh asses on the line we got
skin in the game
right we need to show something right
when elon says
we are doing the model 3 you know or the
cyber truck
unveiling yes on such and such a date
and you know we've been in some of those
things that we get the invitations in
advance
like the engineers have to hit that they
can't miss it
no there could be there has to be a
cyber truck at the cyber truck launch
you're right
right right and so those those events
those launch events get scheduled months
in advance and
the invitations go out the press there's
a press announcement
and so the whole company i mean starting
with the leader puts their
you know butts on the line to hit that
launch date skin in the game
just like the sales team right the sales
team has skin in the game
because they got that quarterly review
if you don't hit your number now you're
on a pip a performance improvement plan
you don't hit your number two quarters
in a row you're out right is that how
you ran it
um yeah i mean what what's what's really
helpful about sales is you get customer
feedback right away
right so like if the if the customer's
not buying what you're selling
you find out real quick and you can make
adjustments and
the great thing about a launch event is
it works the same way i mean
if people hate it you're going to find
out really quickly and that's a good
dynamic to have
now a lot of families don't want it's
scary a lot of founders are too scared
that they might hear something they
don't want to hear um but i think
yeah but that's a bad that that's not
it's it's better
to just get the news um you know the
other thing that i think a lot of
founders are scared of you know what
they'll say
in response to this is well no one's
going to show up at our event they're
worried they're going to declare it
they're going to build it no one
will come and you know my experience
with yammer even in the second year
of yammer uh as a startup we were able
to fill a hotel ballroom and get people
to go to our user conference and so
you'd be surprised i mean again we're
talking about startups that are at that
50 to 500 employee stage and
so they've raised a series a or b or c
and you know if they've done that
there's enough of a community of support
that they can rally that community and
fill
you know a you know a room now in
today's
sort of post-covet environment it may
not it's not gonna be a hotel ballroom
anymore it's gonna be a virtual event
a virtual conference that's fine it
could just be a webin you know webinar
you're not gonna have a giant user event
every quarter uh you know you may just
have some sort of webinar and that's
that's fine what's really important is
that you have an audience
so you can see what the reaction is and
that you set the date in advance
and send out the invitations because
it's not just about the external benefit
of generating all that positive
marketing it's about the internal
benefit
of motivating the team to hit a deadline
that you specify in advance
which is the point of this blog post
which is why it resonates so deeply i
think with me and many people is
you know you're trying to reduce chaos
so to reduce chaos and make people feel
good
you have to introduce some
accountability
accountability which is called the date
and you know
manifest itself with the date or the
sales target
accountability actually reduces chaos
and the and that's a what i would i
would assume you would think is a
healthy stress of being at a startup
yes it it it increases accountability it
also increases transparency because
everyone knows what they're working
towards we know that
two and a half months from now we're all
going to be convened together at this
user conference and we're going to have
to
you know deliver and so everyone's
working towards the same goal
and that creates you know tremendous
amount of it synchronize everybody it
creates
you know a lot of esprit de corps uh and
uh for those who don't
speak french esprit de corps means uh i
think you're spirited
to your core like call it fellowship
right right everyone feels like
means the spirit of the group right so
you all feel like you're
you're working on the same team right
kind of like the super bowl effect you
know the super bowl is coming the amount
of
hype of the super bowl they give it that
nice like
i don't know if it's three weeks up
until the the super bowl
get this nice like energy building
towards it